you
they don't want civil society to have
any say in the catastrophe of climate
change because they know that actually
what we're saying is you have to change
your system the idea for the 12 on the
last day of our cop21 was that we were
going to surround us with red line we
develop many many creative ideas working
with artists and activists such as the
inflatable cobblestones producing a kind
of barricade for the 21st century these
silver inflatable cobblestones they can
be played with in the street and then it
would have been used to mark the red
lines around the Sun the idea of the red
line was that these are red lines that
cannot be crossed then minimal
necessities for just a livable planet
these regulars represent the right to an
atmosphere the right to soil the right
to water the right to just transition
and now they actually also represent the
right protest and we know that it's the
social movements that are going to have
to do the real work it's not the
government's it's not the multinationals
and parrots movies a moment where we
have to show that we're strong and that
we can resist even in a state of
emergency because we know that the
climate emergency is much greater
immersion
I